hello everybody mad Luigi here and from
software has given us a trailer for
their upcoming action-adventure game
with RPG elements cicchitto shadows die
twice I'm gonna break down the trailer
scene by scene and talk about what I
think are going to be the most important
new slash different mechanics and a note
before I begin there's more information
on the Japanese website and Suzaku on
the cicchitto subreddit was nice enough
to translate most of it so I'll be using
that information when relevant and I'll
link the post in the description the
trailer starts off with an ominous
Eastern vibe we see an old almost mummy
of a man carving this is bushi of the
desolate temple from the website an
aging man with no left arm he is a
hermit who secludes himself in a
desolate mountain temple furiously
carving countless statues of the Buddha
he gathers up the shinobi after they are
defeated by the commander of Athena then
offers them his assistance we then get a
shot of who will find out is our young
master the prince keeping up on his
literary skills before accompanying us
to a field that made me really think of
neo - the following samurai the ever
mentioned commander of escena strengthen
that line of thought he chops off your
left hand winning the duel for the
purpose of taking away the prince for
his special bloodline to defend against
a Sheena's enemies with unnatural means
according to the website which I take to
mean supernatural occult stuff he then
wake up with the prosthetic arm which
turns out is what we saw in the teaser
and yes it is a grappling hook this fits
because the name of the game sekito is a
shortening of sickie wand no rope which
means one-armed wolf a nice nickname for
our protagonist you also look a bit
zombie like with some dust or ash
covering or making up part of your face
this zombie feature will come back later
this inciting moment in the game could
very well be where you get to go through
character creation as you could say boo
she could give you a new face along with
that new arm a lot of people are
wondering if there will be a character
creation at all and I'm not sure develop
by from software of course published by
Activision that's anyone obviously I
have no idea how this business deal went
but I'm not too worried a lot of people
are and I think with good reason
activist
doesn't have too big a track record of
being completely open to creative design
and intent but I think from software and
the izaki are too big and have too
strong of a vision for their games for
Activision to have any strong creative
sway over the process if they could
handle BAM Co then I trust them to be
able to handle Activision next up we
have what I think is going to be one of
the big gameplay departures from
previous Prem titles this short clip
highlights what looks like actual
stealth gameplay it could just be
something for the trailer but I think if
we're seeing it in game it will be in
game in the final version in some manner
the ability to actually hide next to
slash behind walls points towards a
deeper system of enemy awareness and
aggression the Crouch movement in the
next scene furthers the idea of stealth
crouching behind enemies would make them
less likely to notice you but you move
slower that's the core of crouching in
many games and the only reason I can see
it coming to a fromsoft game is if the
accompanying stealth comes to after a
shot of the prints we have more reason
to believe in stealth implementation
with the protagonists explicitly
sneaking under the floorboards which a
group of enemies are standing on I think
from soft is way too intentional for all
of these signs of stealth play to not
lead to stealth play
so I'm confidently looking forward to it
in cicchitto moving on we get that
all-too-familiar door animation now we
get to move into some meat combat and
the uses of your prosthetic limb some
leaks said that there will be something
like blood-borne strick weapons and this
cleaver in your arm does seem a bit like
that the finishing move after absolutely
annihilating this blokes excuse of a
shield looks like a more fluid form of
the riposte system more fluid combat is
always a plus from the website this is
called ninja kill or an institute where
they're armed with a blade using
prosthetic ninja tools stalking your
enemies or decisively ending a
hard-fought battle with a single killing
blow through an exposed weak point that
is noone satsu a ninja kill the method
doesn't matter all that truly matters is
being good at killing the stalking your
enemy line is just prodding the stealth
confirmed fire in my heart then we get
the second big new mechanic the
grappling hook this could be absolutely
amazing with the earlier shot of rooftop
walking we could have our own little
parkour system which have done well
would make this game move like
the fluidity astir I can imagine my only
concern here is that the actual number
of points you can grapple to could be
very limited and if so it definitely
wouldn't have the same effect as a more
free range grapple a relevant bit of the
website states the earth is the samurais
battlefield it is where the samurai
crawl a talented shinobi is not limited
to the ground and like a bird of prey
can soar above the field of battle we
fight some samurai in this trailer that
and this line make it seem like we're
going to be getting very used to that
enemy type but that will really be able
to take advantage of the grapple against
them so next is another duel
another samurai though you seem to be
doing a bit better in this one this
combat looks a bit more complex than
we're used to with a bit more advanced
blocking features especially those of
your prosthetic arm the red character
that appears here and will show up later
apparently means danger this could mean
that the enemy is within ninja kill
range but I'm very unsure nothing in
this trailer hints to what it actually
means so we'll have to wait to see then
we get another example of hardcore
parkour followed by another ninja kill
execution one important thing to note
about this scene is that the poor sap
getting rolled on is holding a rifle
this puts the game setting if it follows
history as probably around the 1500s or
later this also means that guns are
going to be a weapon type I would assume
we would get to use them to some extent
as well but we know for sure that at
least the enemies will be shooting at us
big boy in the next scene is definitely
on a cycle of occult juice you know what
so is the next guy however the next guy
at least hints that weapon buffing will
return and he lets us see some more more
complex pairing and blocking and then we
have a familiar death sound file but
this is cicchitto shadows die twice one
death wouldn't be good enough and here
we have our final major gameplay change
after you die you get back up you get
two lives now I got to say I have no
idea how this is going to work hmm never
seen a theme on my part some have
suggested that we get no healing items
just these two lives and while that idea
could have some truth I don't think it
would be just that simple doing that
would in effect just double your health
bar which is a bit mundane in and of
itself I am pretty positive that the
Second Life will come with some
differing features than the first but
what those are I don't know
this is a great Avenue for fromsoftware
to try out new things and give us a
different gameplay experience so I
expect it will be pretty cool but we'll
have to wait to see more to actually
have a tangible discussion about it
following your resurrection you stealth
into another ninja kill and Andy Honda
with a familiar sound and a cool little
flip I have no idea what this
caterpillar mummy is other than a boss
and then we have another boss really
cool scene one of my biggest takeaways
is the use of the grappling hook
mid-fight it looks like a fairly fluid
interaction so we should be able to
weave it into our play styles however we
want the mechanics of the boss's spear
and chucking you and throwing it around
with a tether both give the fight a
deeper complexity than just a guy with a
spear so that's good to see we ended
with a firecracker stun of the horse
another prosthetic arm tool I think
we'll be getting a lot of use out of
this arm probably in the form of weapons
and different upgrades that would give
more of a tangible upgrade path than has
been in recent from soft games other
than just upping damage which is hard to
call a path and that concludes the
trailer of course other than teasing the
giant snake
it comes out in 2019 to all platforms
the all platforms part makes me happy
the 2019 less so just a bit of closing
news some leaks said that the game is
much more heavily single-player than the
souls borne games and the website lists
it as single-player as opposed to
single-player including online up to
four to six or whatever the number is
for the respective souls board game this
could mean co-op as we know it isn't
coming back which would be too bad we'll
have to wait for more official
information though oh wow another theme
that's it for me
I recommend heading over to the psyche
Doh subreddit as there's more
information there that I didn't cover in
this video and I'm sure there'll be some
of the first ones talking about new info
as it releases I'll link it in the
description thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next video